Regular exercise.
A healthy diet.
Maintaining healthy blood pressure, cholesterol and blood sugar levels...
...helps stave off dementia as we grow older.
Dementia is not a normal part of aging.
But age is a huge risk factor.
As people live longer, health agencies and researchers around the world...
...are focusing on ways to prevent, stop or treat dementia...
...including Alzheimer's disease, one of the most common types of dementia.
Alright, are you good?
Let's do it.
David Shorr is about to undergo a new procedure for early stage Alzheimer's disease.
A layer of cells called a blood brain barrier protects the brain from infection.
It also makes it difficult to treat neurodegenerative diseases.
Shorr was diagnosed with Alzheimer's at age 56.
He and his wife are open to trying any new treatment that might help.
Dr. Vibhor Krishna told them about the clinical trial.
Shorr became part of a new clinical trial that tests a procedure...
...that uses MRI guided imaging to target the part of the brain...
...responsible for memory and cognition.
That's where Alzheimer's patients have a buildup of toxic proteins called amyloid.
Simply opening this barrier might help clear amyloid from the brain.
Opening the barrier may one day allow doctors to deliver medication...
...straight to the site of the disease.
Shorr is glad to be part of a trial...
...that could help patients like himself in the early stages of Alzheimer's disease.
Carol Pearson, VOA News.